The next case,
American standard versus Szuchman again,
deals with a case of
incomplete performance,
but it comes to exactly the
opposite conclusion from Pv House,
which we saw in the last lecture
and Jacob and Young's versus Kent,
which we saw in the
beginning of the course.
The plaintiff in this
case as American standard,
which ran a pig iron manufacturing plant
on the Niagara River at the western end
of New York state.
When they decided to close the plant,
they contracted with Harold Shechtman,
a demolition and excavating contractor
who paid $275,000 to buy the buildings
and other structures and most of the
equipment in exchange for these Shechtman.
Also promise quote to
remove the equipment,
demolish the structures and grade the
property as specified in preparation for
American standards. Sale of
the property. As it turns out,
Shechtman did not comply with
these contractual requirements.
There was quote,
a substantial deviation from the required
grade lines unquote and there were
still walls, foundations and other
structures jutting out from the ground,
but the time,
by the time of trial,
American standard had nevertheless
succeeded in selling the property.
For $183,000 which Shechtman contended
was only $3,000 less than its fair market
value at trial.
The judge instructed the jury that the
proper measure of damages was the cost of
completion, not the dimunition
in the property's value.
The jury went on to award
American Standard $90,000
in damages rather than the
$3,000 the check man argued for.
We are reading the decision from the
appellate division of the Supreme Court of
New York.
Recall that New York confusingly uses
the term supreme court for its lowest
level of courts.
The question on appeal was whether the
plaintiff was entitled only to difference
in value damages rather
than cost of completion.
Justice Hancock ruled for the plaintiffs,
but his opinion is not
entirely satisfying.
Just as Hancock reasoning takes cost
of completion as the default rule.
In the usual case quote,
where the contractor's performance
has been defective, were in complete,
the reasonable cost of replacement
or completion is the measure unquote.
His task is to figure out
whether precedents like
Jacob and young versus Kent
require him to deviate
from this general rule.
Jacob and Young's as a decision of the
court of appeals of New York was binding
precedent for this case.
As you'll recall,
the rule there was that when the cost of
completion was grossly and unfairly out
of proportion to the good to be attained,
the court would calculate damages based
on diminution in value rather than cost
of completion.
In that case,
judge Cardosa found that requiring a
contractor to replace an inadvertent
substitution of an equally good pipe with
the contracted brand would be grossly
disproportionate and so Cardoza awarded
only the minimal diminution in value
just as Hancock makes three arguments
for distinguishing American standard and
check man versus Shechtman
from Jacob and Young's.
The first argument rests
on the distinction between
unintentional good faith
emissions and intentional ones.
He relies on Judge Cardozo statement
in Jacob and Young's that quote it
contractor who would ask the court to
apply the diminution in value measure as
an instrument of justice must not have
breached the contract intentionally and
must show substantial performance
made in good faith. In this case,
the contractor denied that the contract
even required him to do the grading.
He was now being sued for failing to do.
It clearly wasn't an oversight.
He intended not to grade a the property
as the court found the contract
required.
Academics have supported this distinction
as a test for what type of damages to
award.
In the 1982 article,
Patricia Marshall argued that the key
factor is whether the breach was willful
or non willful,
the highest possible damages,
usually cost of completion should be
awarded where the breaching party is
willful in order to deter
such willful breaches.
One thing that made puzzle you about
this argument though is that the mining
company and Pv House seems to have behaved
even more egregiously, more willfully,
and yet the PV houses received
only damages equal to the
dimunition in value of
their property.
We will see that the courts,
other arguments are similarly
out of alignment with Pv House.
The court's second main argument is
about what counts as economic waste for
purposes of Jacob and Young's.
In this case,
the court tells us that disparity in
relative economic benefits is not the
equivalent of economic waste,
which was invoked in Jacob
and young versus Kent,
but it doesn't really give us a
satisfying substitute rule. Instead,
it it counters with the principal
from Chamberlain versus Parker that a
landowner is allowed to build a quote
monument to his caprice or folly and that
the court will still enforce a contract
even where performance of the contract
would diminish the value
of of the owner's land,
at least the market value
of the owner's land.
It a line of cases where like here,
plaintiff sought and received cost of
completion damages far exceeding any
increase in the lands market value.
The problem with this line of
argument is that it proves too much.
Why wasn't Kent's desire for reading pipe
a monument to his caprice or folly and
therefore deserving of
cost of completion damages.
The court attempts to argue that's a
key distinction of economic waste is
defects in construction
which are irremediable
irremediable or which may not be
repaired without a substantial tearing
down of the structure as in Jacob and
Young's,
but pvs did not involve any tearing down
of structures or irremediable defects
there.
The mining company simply
failed to fulfill its
obligation to remediate and yet
it only had to pay for
dimunition of value.
Timothy and purists has argued that the
way to distinguish monuments to one's
own folly from cases like this one is
to look at subjective versus objective
value.
In PB house,
the owners intended to keep the property
and the main purpose of the restoration
was to improve their subjective
enjoyment of the property.
The same goes for monument to folly cases.
Mirror suggests that in these cases
the correct measure is cost of per
completion since the plane is truly
want the end result of completion.
On the other hand, in this case,
American standard, uh, in this case,
American standard sold the
property immediately and so
we can conclude that it's
only real interest in the
land was its market value.
In cases such as this one muris argues
the dimunition in value of the property
is the proper measure of damages.
The third distinction,
the court attempts to draw is between
the main purpose of the contract and
incidental purposes.
Just just Handcock argues that the Pv
House court gave only dimunition of value
damages because the failure to restore
the land was only incidental to the
contract whose main purpose was to
extract coal. On the other hand,
he views the grading work as central
to the purpose of the contract between
American standard versus Shechtman.
Rather than provide arguments
for these positions,
just as Hancock merely says that the
grading quote cannot be said to be
incidental.
He claims without justification.
That Shechtman quote can hardly assert
that what he left unfinished was of
trivial or an appreciable importance,
but we very much could dispute that.
The courts assertion,
remember who was pain,
whom here Shechtman paid American
standard more than a quarter of a million
dollars to purchase it's old equipment.
From that perspective.
The agreement to grade the property seems
incidental or no less incidental than
the bargain Ford contract provisions
the PV houses had with the garland coal
company.
Both the cost of performance
and definition and value
damage measures can be
see.
They can be seen as ways of implementing
expectation damages but they do so
under different assumptions about what
the plaintiff will do with the damage.
Money.
Cost of performance implicitly assumes
that the plaintiff will take the damages
and use it to actually
purchase performance.
Cost of performance accordingly puts
the plaintiff in the position she would
have been in if the defendant
had performed by giving
the plaintiff's sufficient
funds to buy substitute
performance dimunition in value.
Damages on the other hand implicitly
assume that plaintiff is not interested in
using the money to buy substitute
performance and instead tries to put the
plaintiff in the same economic position
as if performance had occurred by giving
her sufficient funds to compensate for
any dimunition in value caused by the
plaintiffs breach.
What's particularly perverse about
the [inaudible] decision is that the
plaintiff has no opportunity to use the
money to purchase substitute performance
because American standard is already sold.
The property giving costs it performance
in such a situation can overcompensate
providing uh,
the plaintiff with the kind of windfall.
One idea for how to improve this legal
mess is to allow plaintiffs to choose
between damages for dimunition in value
or specific performance but not damages
for cost of completion.
We're playing this really do want to
wrecked monuments to their own folly.
They can insist on specific
performance by the defendant,
but American standard wouldn't really
have wanted specific performance since it
didn't have any remaining
interest in having the property
graded proper properly.
Now that the property had been sold,
all it lost was the value of the property.
And so it would settle with
Szuchman for anything over $3,000.
Of course plaintiffs like American
standard could still sue for specific
performance and then use
that or court order, uh,
in order to bargain for significant
side payments from the defendants who
otherwise would have to pay the
entire cost of completing the contract
themselves.
And now let's look at this quiz.
Imagine that mark hires a contractor to
build an incredibly ugly building on his
property.
If built the building,
we'll actually blight the view and
reduced the value of Mark's property,
the contractor poor as a foundation,
but then fails to complete the project.
In which of the following situations is
it more appropriate to calculate damages
based on cost of completion?
A mark is planning to live on the
property for the rest of his life.
The building has been designed by his
favorite modernist architect or B.
Mark is misguided is a misguided real
estate developer hoping to flip the
property. He thinks the building,
we'll get him a better price for it.
Well,
you should see that cost of completion
damages are more appropriate in situation
a here mark seeks to get the
subjective value of the building,
which he appreciates
even if no one else does.
In professor [inaudible] view
cases involving subjective value,
just justify damages based on cost of
completion in situation be the only value
of the building to mark isn't its ability
to make the property more valuable
when sold.
This is a matter of objective value.
And so courts should award damages
based on the dimunition in market value,
which in this case is likely
to be very small or even zero.
We have seen great inconsistency and the
case is about when the proper measure
of damages is dimunition of value
as opposed to cost of completion.
You should be aware that
some considerations that
courts take into account when
deciding which type of
damages to allow our,
whether the nonconformity
was willful or accidental,
whether the case involves subjective or
objective value and the centrality of
the admission to the original agreement.
But keep in mind that the default
rule remains cost of completion.